faan welcome back to St Louis your home
welcome back to grch St also we started
to speak about the candidates about the
main tournament one of the main
tournaments of 2024 so what do you think
in general about the State of Affairs in
the Chess World on the top let's say
with Magnus who is like dropped some
points here there dingly ran who is
absent for absent for so long like
what's going on in the last
year yeah for sure it's a very unusual
situation uh I think that Magnus he
achieved everything that he could want
in chess in general um so he probably
didn't see any more value in terms of
playing of course there's always money
but maybe he doesn't uh worry so much
about the money anymore and he was more
thinking I don't need this and I don't
really want to go through this process
which I can understand on some level of
course because the uh stress and the
pressure and all the everything that
comes with playing a world championship
match or candidates tournament it it
does of course take a lot of energy out
of you so uh at some point we have to
make these personal decisions do we want
to pursue success or do we want to take
care of our personal uh life more let's
say so this is just a personal decision
decision it seems like he uh has less
interest in classical chess as a whole I
think this is not a revelation he said
it himself that he wants to focus more
on rapid chess Blitz chest maybe some
other forms of chest like chest 960 or
uh or other things
in terms of ding I I really can't say so
much because he's less public than
Magnus so we we don't know his thoughts
as much but he has been remarkably
absent I mean he hasn't played anything
or had like let's say a meaningful sort
of um role in the Chess World since he
became world champion he played one
event the grand chess Tour event in
Bucharest it was yeah it was very
unsuccessful for him and he didn't play
any other events he said that he will
come back next year that's what what we
can kind of maybe for the world T
supermat maybe for that he said that he
would come back in January to play an
event uh if so that that'll be
interesting to see his return I'm also
very interested to see how he plays
after a long
break um and yeah in terms of the next
match of course it'll be very
interesting whoever he faces um yeah I I
think that we we're seeing a little bit
of a transition maybe in terms of other
players who are getting more motivated
magna's taking more of a step back from
classical chess Ting being a little bit
of a wild card now actually speaking
about Magnus and the fact that he
doesn't want to play classical chest
that much um do you think it's a chance
for you actually to be on top and now
you're second player in the in the world
and so do this Gap is not so big anymore
so would you try to actually to be on
the top I I've always tried I mean I
I've I've always tried um Magnus was
always a a huge obstacle let's say for
every player who was trying to become uh
the best in the world and at some point
we were close but he always had that uh
bit of an edge on me in terms of results
and at some point I was catching up a
bit but then uh also at some points
falling behind because I didn't have the
consistency that he has and I lost my
motivation during the co years
completely uh this was I think uh I
wasted a lot of time during those years
so maybe it was my own fault but also I
think the world situation was a little
bit difficult in confusing and the Chess
World as well it wasn't exactly clear
what would happen uh in the Chess World
to chess tournaments to the future of
Chess or the world in general so um yeah
definitely lost a bit of time and I
think what what about now it's just 30
something points no to me it's it's less
about the rating because I understand
ratings go up and down and
um yeah maybe Magnus lost a bit of
rating recently but um I'm not thinking
too much about about the rating for me
the main goal is really the candidates
tournament and uh do it performing well
there and Performing well in general so
um I think that Magnus has always taken
a pragmatic view of tournaments as in
he's he's trying to win the tournament
he's not trying to gain rating or
anything so uh I also feel like this is
the most important that um yeah it's
it's all about the tournaments and
playing well and uh and the results
usually come if you're in good shape yes
so this what I wish you I mean all the
best of luck in this in this tournament
thank you thank you
[Music]
thanks